foreign
[Music]
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists got malabama here
hi everybody TK Coleman what it is we've
got a very special guest for you today
we've got the rest of our team here in
the studio as well coming up today on
this free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about wealth and
money clutter and her reservations about
investing without a purpose we also have
an outstanding lightning round segment a
live stream question and a listener tip
for you you can check out the full three
hour maximal edition of episode 388
where we answer four times the questions
and we dive deep into several simple
living segments that private podcast
episode is out right now at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck let's start with our
callers if you have a question or
comment for our show we'd love to hear
from you give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Elita
my name is Elita I'm from Salem Oregon
and I'm a private podcast subscriber
minimalism to me means letting go of
attachments to things to ideas to
anything that's cluttering up your life
and preventing you from living a full
and happy life
but I'm unsure of how to approach a
minimalist mindset around investing
investing by Nature it would seem is an
accumulation in order to amass wealth
specifically
and because of the nature of investing
putting money aside into an abstract and
nebulous market and gambling that is
going to earn back more than you
originally put in
seems to be accumulation without a
specific purpose at least to me
I don't have wealth so I would like to
invest for retirement because I don't
plan on working until noon on the day I
die
but let's say I did have wealth let's
say I had all the money I would need in
a lifetime
what is the purpose of investing then to
build Financial Security for my children
they'll already inherit whatever I have
do people who support a minimalist
lifestyle invest
if so what are they Investing For What
is the mindset regarding that if they
don't need any more money for survival
is it simply an attachment at that point
a leader what a thoughtful question I
can't wait to hear a different
perspective on this joining us in the
studio right now to help us tackle this
question is ramit Sethi he has a brand
new Netflix series out actually it comes
out tomorrow on April 18th and it is
called how to get rich now we're going
to unpack that for me but ladies and
gentlemen
dude so happy to have you ma'am thank
you for having me and thanks for having
me back this is awesome yeah last time I
know I think you were out of studio so
it's awesome to be here with you yeah
and uh yeah love the upgraded Studio you
guys are absolute Pros you're in
inspiration to me oh stop that means a
lot coming for me man it's awesome what
year did you publish that
uh the original version of I will teach
you rich came out in 2009 at the bottom
of the recession March 2009 literally
the bottom perfect timing yeah and then
I wrote that one with the black cover is
an updated tenure uh update so that came
out in 2019 and then this journal came
out very recently I want to talk to you
about the journal so we've got I will
teach you to be rich the journal and I'm
gonna start with the latest question
here and if I go to page seven I had
this marked specifically and in here you
talk about because her question is like
what am I saving for and I agree money
becomes clutter if you're just saving
saving saving for the sake of this is
what I'm supposed to do but here in the
journal and I really enjoyed this
because Finance there's an emotional
side of it but there's also the
mechanical side and you help people with
both sides of the sort of the psychology
behind money I'll hold it up if you're
watching the video version of the
podcast but this this journal it gives
you prompts that don't just help you
with the emotional side but actually
help you with the mechanics and I think
elita's question is fundamentally about
the mechanics of okay what am I saving
for because if I'm just supposed to
squirrel away money but I don't realize
why I'm doing it well then what is any
of this for anyway and so here on page
seven you talk about defining what your
rich life might be and it could be
packing up your kids uh lunch or picking
up your kids every day from school right
or buying a thousand dollar cashmere
sweater maybe that's what a rich life
looks like to you or maybe getting
anything you want from whole foods
without ever worrying about the cost not
having to to look at the price tag and
say oh wait uh the other one's 30 30
cents cheaper and all of a sudden I'm
constantly worrying and there's a type
of mental clutter that this type of
financial burden creates within us you
say taking your family on an
unforgettable vacation where they can go
behind the scenes at Disney World with
cast members or buying an extra phone
charger for every room in your house yes
right what your rich life looks like
might be different from your neighbor's
rich life it should be it should be your
rich life should be vastly different
than mine and I bet it is so when I when
I start off talking to people about
money I do not start by saying tell me
about your Roth IRA setup what's your
allocation nobody cares okay I asked
them what's your rich life and pretty
much everybody gives me the same answer
I want to do what I want when I want I
go okay and play this game I go so what
do you want
silence because we're not really taught
to think about what our rich life is we
treat money as a burden oh I should save
and sometimes I just for fun I go why
should you save they go uh because you
know they told me to I need and then
they what happens is people go into
logic I need it for Financial Security I
go that's true how much do you need more
how much a million dollars I go isn't it
different if you live in LA or Manhattan
or Ohio or you know and so we have this
part of our brain that tells us we
should be logical and Save which we
probably should
but we are deeply emotional about money
and then we try to ignore it we try to
cover it up like like emotions are
weakness actually I think that I get a
lot of Joy from being able to go to a
restaurant and Order appetizers without
looking at the price you know why
because when I was a kid we could not
afford appetizers so that's meaningful
to me and then on the other end of the
spectrum I get a lot of Joy being able
to travel and I I'm a hotel guy I love
really nice hotels I have a list I know
the exact room I it's dialed in
and it's very expensive now for me I
love it so I love to spend extravagantly
on the things I love and I cut costs
mercilessly on the things I don't you
know Jazz such as I drive an old car
such as I rent my place
um such as like I keep my computer for
many many years I just don't care about
that stuff and you know it's funny I
remember having a conversation with a
friend of mine
and I told them like I don't really care
about the type of meat I buy at the
grocery store like I get the cheapest
one now I care about how much I'm eating
I have fitness goals but he was like you
don't buy the most expensive whatever
and I was like no I don't care he goes
why not you could afford it like it's
not part of my rich life for the things
that are I want to go way deep on it and
some of it is expensive some of it's
just being able to hang with friends in
the middle of the day free but other
parts of it that I don't care about I go
not for me and that's why my rich life
is mine and your rich life is yours I
see another question in hearing in that
as well and it's kind of like you've
implicitly defined what is my poor life
what are those areas where I'm willing
to be boring so I can be exciting what
are those areas where I'm willing to be
poor so I can be extravagant yeah I
would say poor is a loaded term sure uh
but I definitely think there are areas
where I'm willing to cut back
mercilessly where it's just not worth
even thinking about or spending time or
money on it and then on the other hand
where do I want to go all in and this is
the kind of dynamic I love to see in
people's lives yeah I'm talking about
money specifically but also in other
parts I love when somebody goes you know
what Remy like I have a a friend a
reader of mine
he goes I live a rich life I said how
how is it rich he goes my wife and I use
your material we retired in our mid-30s
we travel in an RV across the country
that's our rich life wow now personally
I find that to be my personal hell
put in an RV yeah he and his wife love
it and I think that's awesome another
reader he loves miniatures
never even thought of it don't even know
anything about it but that's where he
gets his joy and he can spend time and
money to create that rich life I think
that sometimes we have that we have a
very paradoxical relationship with money
on one hand we love it
we have a lot of adulation for it Envy
for it we look at pictures of Bora Bora
on Instagram but on the other hand we
hate it it's puritanical oh money's bad
if I get more money I'm going to be an
and what I love is helping
people start with defining their rich
life and then showing them how they can
use money to live a bigger version of it
and if that means they for example if
you love Miniatures maybe you can buy
some extras maybe if you turn that dial
way up you can travel to South Dakota
where the world's foremost miniature
Creator is doing it and you can take a
tutorial with that person for two weeks
whoa right we can find a way to turn
that dial up and use money to live it
that's what I'm talking about here yeah
man this is uh this is why I love your
book man it's like it's it's Timeless
man it'll it'll always be useful when it
comes to uh money that yeah awesome work
we're talking about well I was gonna say
there's one thing that you talk about in
your book um I'm paraphrasing so like
correct me where I'm wrong but instead
of approaching money from an economic
standpoint it's more of a
we don't really think about the
philosophy or the intellectual side of
that does that apply to elita's question
here alita's question is it can be very
large and existential and it can be very
simple and mechanical so let's take a
look at both of them on the large
existential question what is the purpose
of money why are we saving I mean you
can start making arguments about should
I have more than somebody else next to
me how much is fair and all those
questions I have always focused on
starting with the individual so I write
for one person and that's why when you
read my book you know I'm talking to you
uh but I absolutely agree there are
existential structural questions for
example you know we're here in La
housing is really expensive and so it
would be disingenuous for me to be like
hey guys just save a bunch of money and
then like go buy a house it's so easy
like I hate when people say that yeah oh
save your avocado just like you you
don't understand how costs have
escalated so I think and part of my
philosophy is you can simultaneously
acknowledge the need for systemic reform
as well as
take control of personal responsibility
you can do both and so that is what I
encourage that's why I'm politically
active that's why I want people
especially young people poor people
minorities to have more access to
housing right and I want to show you how
to automate your savings so that would
be the large part of elita's question
why should we save well on a personal
level you need to save because one day
you may get injured you may not have
enough to live or you may need to
provide for a family member
as for the mechanics of it she mentioned
a very offhand quick comment where she
said I don't have wealth and so what
that tells me is she has a lot of
questions and thoughts about it but it's
very easy when you are not engaged in
something to to sort of start spinning
in your head it would be like if I don't
have a podcast at all and then I go well
I don't know if I should use this mic or
that mic and if I use that mic what's it
going to say about me Etc it's like just
get a mic and let's just start and
you'll learn more from doing that yeah
so for Elita I would say
we can actually start with what is your
rich life start with if that's too big
of a question what's your perfect day
what's your perfect week and I bet you
in her perfect week she's not going to
tell me she likes spending three hours
on laundry I guarantee that I bet you
she's going to tell me she maybe wants
to walk her dog in the middle of the
afternoon I go okay cool let's let's
craft something like a chef and I will
show her how an extra
200 bucks a month saved can actually
lead directly to living that version of
her rich life I love it man yeah and
what's what you're illustrating here is
that a plan without a purpose like yes
I'm just saving saving saving is sort of
like a recipe without hunger like here's
your recipe but I don't know what I'm
why am I making all this food if I'm not
hungry right and so what is your rich
life what you're really saying is like
what do you hunger for I love that yeah
I love that we all intuitively
understand where this can go wrong if we
think about anyone in our family or an
older friend
who has saved and saved for 20 30 40
years
and they kept telling themselves you
know I need enough for retirement when I
retire that I'm going to travel
suddenly here they are 60 70 75 years
old
and they are not doing any of the things
they said they would they're not
traveling it may be because they're
injured or they they can't or may simply
because they never built the skills to
actually spend their money what a
tragedy what a tragedy to go your entire
life telling yourself oh one day I'm
gonna flip the page and magically turn
into this other person and then you and
I and we all know human nature you're
not going to change it's very difficult
especially at the age of 70 to do it
yeah so my encouragement for everybody
here is there are some things in life
that cannot wait they cannot be done
serially like one after another they
have to be done together making friends
is one you can't be like I'm not going
to make friends tell them 55. it's like
dude you're a loner for the rest of your
life don't do it that's right and you
cannot wait it's it's increasingly
difficult to become physically fit later
in life it can be done but it's much
more difficult and it is very difficult
to save money
and to spend money as you get later in
life that is a skill
to spend money meaningfully that must be
cultivated today and tomorrow and that's
what I've been really talking about
recently yeah and it's not because the
universe gives you a deadline
arbitrarily like nope you're over 40 you
can't learn anything new it's more of
these things emanate from a mindset it's
kind of like in sports why trying to
flip the switch is so dangerous we'll
play the whole season being really lazy
then we'll turn it up in the playoffs
but when you get to the playoffs you
can't escape your habits overnight and
so I love your answer here to this
question that it's really about the
mindset which is the correlation with
what we talk about with minimalism so
did you hear that everyone get rid of
your storage units full of avocado toast
it's not doing anything for you no real
quick I just want to say one thing about
minimalism because what Elita mentioned
was amazing about not just the physical
physical stuff but she went into all the
non-physical things and how the point is
to let go I would just throw a caveat
there and say minimalism it gives you
the opportunity to loosen your grip
which then presents the opportunity to
let go if you want to and it sounds like
like her idea and her ideology towards
money maybe she wants to loosen her grip
on that because she has this Firm Stance
on I shouldn't save any money because
that's accumulate that's accumulation
but
um if you even gotta let go of the the
whole minimalism idea that's okay too
like that's what it can do for you so um
yeah yeah save away Elita yeah I mean
I'm gonna send you a copy of I will
teach you to be rich the journal I think
you'll find immense value in it there's
also a section in there I think we'll
talk about it here on the podcast in a
bit about rewiring your beliefs around
money I think that would be especially
helpful for you
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your questions from Tick
Tock yes indeed you can follow the
minimalist on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalists
during the lightning round we each have
60 seconds to answer your questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response we'll put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media you can find
those show notes at the minimalists.com
podcast it looks like honey has a
question for us if the opposite of love
and hate is indifference but I'm still
mad as hell does that mean I'm still in
love all right so this is a throwback to
we had Dr Courtney Warren on the show
and uh she was talking about how the
opposite of love is not hate the
opposite of love and hate is indifferent
so just for some context here and that
video went wild on Tick Tock people
responding like I feel what she's saying
but I still hate him so much and what
honey is saying here is look I get it
maybe the opposite of Love is
indifference but I'm not indifferent
right now I'm still mad as hell for
whatever happened I'm sorry honey that
something happened to you here it's
weird to say I'm sorry honey no I was
like I'm like oh yeah her name is honey
I'm sorry darling I thought you're like
honey let me tell you something
so is she still in love uh let's put 60
seconds on the clock for Ryan Nicodemus
what do you got for us Ryan anger is a
symptom of broken expectations it's not
just anger though it's really any
negative emotion sadness jealousy Envy
whatever it is whenever we experience a
negative emotion it's because we have
expected something of someone or
ourselves that isn't being met so when
it comes to Honey's question
when it comes to any of our negative
emotions we have to ask ourselves what
is the expectation that is being broken
and is it worth having that expectation
and risking it for all those negative
emotions that we allow to come in
holding on to that thing I love what
you're saying here you're not saying you
need to get rid of your expectations but
is it worth holding on to this
expectation yeah let's put 60 seconds on
the clock for TK Coleman
hatred is merely love and disgust if I'm
truly nonchalant emotionally detached
disinterested and indifferent
you can't make me hate you you can't
make me hate that thing you're putting
in front of my face think about some
time when maybe a little kid got mad at
you and they said well you're a you're a
green colored dragon with seven heads do
you get your feelings hurt do you get
angry at them you laughed right because
there's nothing in you that's connected
to that there's nothing in you that
believes that that has those questions
about yourself the only thing that can
get a rise out of you is the thing that
resonates with something that is burning
within you and so when we find ourselves
hating people it's because there is
something about them and what they could
be or what we could be together with
them and they are deviating from that so
strongly that it fills us with this
extreme disappointment manifesting
itself as I hate you but if you didn't
love them at one time or love them for
what they could be you would never feel
that you call me anything you want but a
chair
[Laughter]
about that he doesn't even have a chair
we don't even give him a a c word
you know one of my favorite am I I think
the most joyous kid that I've ever met
is our friend Griffin house the very
talented musician his youngest daughter
Clara and the first time we went over to
his house in Nashville his daughter the
first time I ever met her she walks up
behind me and she Whispers in my ear I
could set you on fire right now
[Laughter]
she was thinking you're well known but I
could really blow you up right right
exactly but what she's saying is like
you're the green dragon I don't take it
seriously it was cute but if Jordan just
came up to me mid podcast and said I
could set you on fire right now I mean
I'm going to see it as a threat yeah so
context is everything here give me 60
seconds I'd love to share something with
honey
you are not in love
love
is in you
yes you may be really pissed off at the
person that you love they may make you
angry and you may feel like I hate you
and you may be struggling to find that
indifference or maybe you're just
struggling to find the calm that you
want maybe you had a terrible breakup
maybe you had a relationship that just
ended in a way you didn't want it to end
and now you feel pissed you feel upset
you feel offended you're not wrong for
that your emotions aren't wrong you feel
how you feel
but also understanding that it's not
about being in love with that person
the love that you experience means
you're witnessing them you're also
witnessing the anger that you feel
you're witnessing those so-called
negative emotions and you're seeing how
they make you feel and as soon as you
see them that's when you're able to drop
them
let's check in with our patreon live
stream here in a moment but first real
quick for our right here right now
segment here's one thing that's going on
in the life of the minimalist speaking
of breakups Ryan bye bye to social
justice actually this isn't a breakup at
all no Jess is finally graduating from
the minimalists yeah we've been working
with her for eight years now from we had
a very long tour in 2014 and then 2015
she came on board she's been all over
the world with us she's been monitoring
and posting on our social media for
almost a decade now and then we put we
sent her off on maternity leave
um when was this uh back in the fall of
last year and she was on maternity leave
for three months she came back and then
she gave us a call a couple weeks ago
and she was like Hey I'm not able to do
this
job with the same level of quality that
I once brought to it because my life
circumstances have changed and I would
feel bad staying in this predict of
putting you in this predicament and she
goes this is the most difficult phone
call I've ever had to make and I'm like
I don't want it to be a difficult phone
call
we totally understand yeah it just
because your life circumstances have
changed and we've done our best to
accommodate you and you've done your
best to accommodate us the thing that
fits before may not fit in the future
and so she's decided that she wants to
leave full-time work
but the side she needs to let go at
least for this chapter of her life of
full-time work
and to that I say Brava for that
realization I'm glad you're in a
circumstance where you can do that but
yes we love you and we're so grateful
for the many years that you've spent
with us I remember when she first called
me when she was pregnant
and I was sitting here in this chair
and we were on FaceTime together and so
this is almost a year ago now
and she goes Josh I've got to tell you
something I'm pregnant and I don't know
why my subconscious came to the
Forefront TK and you know my first words
to her were
oh no
I'm sorry
what it was almost I was conflating
something in my head like maybe my wife
was calling me and telling me that right
which still that response in that moment
would not be a very good response but I
said oh no we've got your back this is
awesome for you you something you really
want wonderful and that illustrates
perfectly what we were talking about
earlier with ramit especially on the
private podcast how your version of a
rich life might look appreciably
different from my version of a rich life
so if I try to hand you my template of
what a meaningful life looks like here's
we've identified the hundred things you
need to own the job one of the three
jobs you must have and exactly how much
money you must contribute to charity
every year and there you'll have your
meaningful life and then you do all
those things you're like wait a minute
I actually feel more stressed out I feel
more overwhelmed this life isn't for me
oh okay it's because what a meaningful
life looks like for you might be
different from what it looks like for me
when I talked to her I told her she'd
never work in this town again
she's like I don't plan on coming back
I'm like you better not
that was funny she was like I don't want
you I don't want to let you down I don't
want you to be mad at me and it was yeah
it was interesting because
um I mean it is it's hard to let go I
mean when when something changes
especially that's you know something
that's been around for eight years like
it's never easy to let go of that that
past that Nostalgia but um no she's
wonderful and like yeah I was like dude
I'm happy for you like it's great that
you're able to go out and start this new
chapter in your life and thanks for
being with us when you were and if you
need a good recommendation we got your
back on that yes yeah I remember Ryan
when you and I worked the same
Corporation in the corporate world we
would often know that some were hiring
someone but there's maybe a two-year
three-year term limit on their job there
yeah and it wasn't like well actually
you know we're only hiring lifers
because you get a particular kind of
person who's a lifer right but maybe
it's also like I'm helping this person
through the next chapter of their life
and if if I can support them in a way
that enhances their life then they're
probably going to show up as the best
version of themselves for those two or
three or five or ten years whatever it
is and that's exactly what happened with
Jess my favorite Jess story is we got to
a point maybe two years in that she was
so disorganized she was a pillar of
disorganization it was chaos her
organization system sucked and she knew
it she just couldn't get a hold of it
and eventually eventually Ryan and I had
to have this conversation with her like
hey I'm sorry but this just isn't
working out can we help you get better
organized like I don't think she even
understood how disorganized she was she
just knew there was chaos everywhere and
she turned it around over the course of
the next six months turned it around so
much that she is now the Paragon of
organization anytime Mallory or Sean or
or Jordan or Dan or anyone else needs to
organize something I say hey you need to
go talk to Jess because she can organize
she can show you exactly how she creates
her flow charts or and her Asana board
and and her calendars and all of these
things not so you can mimic it exactly
but you can get a few ingredients from
her and create your own version to well
organize the to provide order to the
chaos so Jess we love you you can follow
her on social media just breathes on
Instagram is we'll put a link to that in
the show notes as well but Jess
you will always have a very very special
part in this chapter called the
minimalists we're so grateful for you
let's tune into the patreon live
we have a question here from Ella she
says my husband says we need whole life
insurance because of our high net worth
as an investment we've had this policy
for 10 years but should we cancel this
policy and cut our losses so we're going
to dive into this on the private podcast
quite a bit in fact we talk about three
Financial myths that are total scams
they're nonsense that you want to avoid
and one of those is whole life insurance
nothing wrong with term life insurance
but when you're buying Insurance you're
not investing when I buy car insurance
or home insurance or flood insurance or
hurricane insurance or business
insurance it is Insurance in case
something goes wrong it's an emergency
fund in a way you're you're investing in
an emergency you're not actually making
an investment in your future so to speak
so whole life insurance we're going to
talk about why that is
quite often a scam actually it's always
a scam even when people don't have the
intention to scam you it's not the best
investment for your money we're going to
talk about some other myths that we want
to bust in terms of your finances as
well we'll check back in with the
patreon live stream as well but in the
meantime malibam what else you got for
us here's a minimalist Insight from one
of our listeners
hey Ryan hey Josh this is Lisa from
Minnesota my advice to your listeners
who are moving and are wondering what to
take and what to leave behind is imagine
you are in your new home and you open a
box and you there is a saying that you
are wondering about whether you want to
take and are you thinking wow I'm so
glad to see this I cannot wait to use
this in my new home or are you thinking
oh man what the heck was I thinking why
did I pack this what the heck am I going
to do with this so hopefully this will
make things more clear to you listeners
thanks
all right y'all that's our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full three hour maximal
edition of episode 388 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions like
how much money is enough money how does
the cost of living factor into Financial
Planning and what are some practical
ways that we can battle inflation plus
we've got a million more questions for
ramit and the minimalists and we have an
argument about our friend Dave Ramsey
ramit thinks he's not on the same page
as Dave and we'll try to unpack that on
the private podcast also this week a
private minimalist home tour from one of
our listeners it is one of the most
remarkable playrooms slash bedrooms that
I have ever seen we also have a sucky ad
segment that really makes TK upset I
thought he was gonna walk out of the
studio at one point oh was he upset I
also have much much more of lesson if
you want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast this week
over at patreon.com the minimalist or
click the link in the description to
subscribe and get your personal link so
that our weekly Maxwell episodes play in
your favorite podcast app you'll also
gain access to all of our podcast
archives all the way back to episode
zero zero one and if you're still on the
fence here's a testimonial from one of
our lovely patreon supporters Kayla says
I wasn't sure whether I'd like the
minimalist podcast having a third host
added to the show
you guys made the right choice bringing
TK on board I love the private podcast
discussions they're entertaining
meaningful and insightful Kayla thank
you so much yeah Kayla I'm dedicating
today's Christmas song to you
big thanks to ramit safety for joining
us today we'll put a link to his new
Journal as well as his new Netflix
series in the show notes and if you
leave here today with just one message
what if he does
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing
little things you think that you need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed or I bet that you'll be fine
without it foreign